this projection from Spain's Met Office
shows the country seeing record-breaking
temperatures by Thursday and Friday
Inland areas like Cordoba expected to
reach 15 degrees above normal with highs
of around 40 degrees celsius remember
this is in April and currently 27 of
Spanish territory is classified as in
drought emergency or drought alert and
this shows the 55 hottest temperatures
ever recorded in Spain you can see not
many back in the past the frequency
really increasing over the last few
years including the highest ever
47.6 degrees Celsius in Cordoba in 2021
but as hot as it is on the land in so
many places scientists are just as
alarmed about what's happening in the
ocean this shows the surface sea
temperature for the world's oceans
excluding the polar regions you can see
last year 2022 2016 which is hotter and
we'll talk about why in a bit compared
to the average for 1981 to 2011 which is
much much lower and let's have a look at
2023 this dark red line you see the
trajectory is much steeper this is
unprecedented
now this is what the ocean temperatures
looked like yesterday compared to the
average from 1971 to 2000 red yellow is
not good and that has serious effects on
everything from Life in the ocean itself
to wildfires and extreme weather
conditions on land now remember we
talked about 2016 how it's extremely
warm that was because alongside General
Ocean warming is also supercharged by a
powerful El Nino the cyclical weather
event now if you look at this area of
water close to South America just to its
West it's already very warm there in the
red scientists think this could mean the
start of another El Nino potentially
another powerful one the defects of that
develop over months and years so as warm
as 2023 is likely to be on land and on
sea 2024 could be even hotter